wirtschaftsminister robert habeck ist am
abend bei maischberger und das was er zu
drohenden insolvenzen sagt also zu
betrieben die vor der pleite stehen das
ist teilweise wirklich absurd main
einige warum werden mal rein das sehen
wir jetzt überall das leben die darauf
angewiesen sind dass die menschen geld
ausgeben blumenläden bioläden bäckereien
gehören dazu dass die wirkliche probleme
haben weil ist eine kaufzurückhaltung
gibt und dann sind die nicht insolvent
automatisch aber sie hören vielleicht
auch zu verkaufen und das ist nicht
aufhöre zu verkaufen verdiene ich kein
geld mehr da muss ich die insolvenz
anmelden nach zwei monaten wenn ich
nicht getan habe habe ich in so würde
man würde dann insolvent werden wenn man
mit der arbeit immer größeres minus
macht ja aber wie wollen sie denn kein
größeres minus machen wenn sie leute
bezahlen aber dies wir verkaufen also
wie soll man also ich hab es nicht
verstehe ich weiß dass ich automatisch
eine insolvenzwelle geben geben muss
aber es kann sein dass ich bestimmte
geschäfte nicht mehr rentieren und hier
dann eingestellt werden vielleicht
werden sie später wieder aufgenommen das
kann ja sein also das ist dann ja keine
klassische insolvenz frau wagenknecht so
erklärt robert habeck eine insolvenz
beziehungsweise eine nicht insolvenz man
merkt auf jeden fall braucht nachhilfe
vertrauen sie diese minister dennoch
also ich meine dem kann man ja nicht
vertrauen ich muss sagen als ich das
gesehen habe ich war einfach fassungslos
also ich glaube wir befinden uns in
einer dramatischen situation
deutschland steuert wegen dieser
explodierenden energiepreise auf eine
wirtschaftliche und soziale katastrophe
zu und wir haben im
wirtschaftsministerium jemanden sitzen
der offenbar elementare wirtschaftliche
zusammenhänge nicht kennt oder nicht
durchschaut oder nicht durchschauen will
und ich mein ok man kann ja mal einen
ausfall haben man kann mal einen abend
schlecht drauf sein also das könnte man
ja noch hinnehmen aber ehrlich gesagt
das ist ja nicht der erste ausfall ich
mein während andere länder zum beispiel
energiepreise deckeln in frankreich
steigt steigt der strompreis in diesem
jahr um vier prozent im ganzen jahr der
sprit diesel und benzin sind um 40 cent
pro liter billiger als hier und während
also hier alles weiter nach oben geht
hat unser toller wirtschaftsminister die
idee mache ich noch mal ein bisschen was
oben drauf machen gas um lage und lässt
auch noch die energie lobbyisten diese
gasanlage also das gesetz dafür
schreiben und wundert sich dann dass es
genauso aussieht wie es aussieht wenn
hobbyisten von unternehmen sich ein
gesetz basteln nämlich ein
selbstbedienungsladen also insoweit das
ist ja eine folge von ausfällen und ich
sag mal wenn nur ein minister schlecht
drauf wäre in dieser ampel obwohl das
ist ja ein schlüssel ressort aber auch
das wäre schon schlimm genug aber es ist
ja die ganze regierung ich meine die
haben den ernst der lage nicht erkannt
und auf diesen wirrwarr
wirtschaftsminister hat friedrich merz
reagiert in der bundestagsdebatte und da
waren wir auch ein wenn sie können die
hoch komplexen fragen der energiepolitik
in der versorgungssicherheit unseres
landes in einer solchen existenziellen
krise doch nicht allen ernstes einen
bundeswirtschaftsminister überlassen der
zwar wie wir immer wieder sehen gefällig
formulieren kann dem wir immer wieder
beim denken zuschauen dürfen der aber
umgeben ist sie aber umgeben ist ganz
offensichtlich in seiner partei und in
seinem apparat von einer gruppe aus
lobbyisten der umweltpolitik die alles
zur strecke bringen was auch nur
einigermaßen aussicht auf erfolg hat
diese krise in dem sektor mit verlaub
wie hilflos er habe sie in diesen fragen
sind das konnte man gestern abend im
deutschen fernsehen wo was man kann
man kann nur hoffen dass
ein großteil der deutschen
mittelständischen unternehmer und vor
allem der bäckerinnen und bäcker um
diese uhrzeit schon im bett gelegen
haben und geschlafen haben und das nicht
mit ansehen mussten was sie da gestern
abend von sich gegeben hat man kann sich
nur ob
friedrich merz kritisierte
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe sehr
stark und es gibt eine umfrage bei uns
auf der homepage bei bild und da haben
wir gefragt ob unsere leser dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister noch zutrauen
das ruder wieder herumzureißen die
energie krise zu meistern und das ist
nicht gut ausgefallen das profunde auf
wunder muss man auch sagen nach dem
auftritt gestern bei maischberger fast
95 prozent derjenigen die abgestimmt
haben und das sind zu diesem zeitpunkt
fast hunderttausend nutzer von bild.de
hier sehen wir es 93 prozent sind es
genau sieben prozent sagen ja herberg
wird uns gut durch die krise bringen 93
prozent sagen nein wie gesagt bei rund
100.000 user die schon abgestimmt haben
ist das natürlich ein deutliches urteil
das war jetzt eine wirklich gute
einfache vorlage für friedrich merz ein
elfmeter den er auch verwandelt hat aber
die frage die dahinter steckt ist
natürlich in wirklichkeit wie wie solide
sitzt robert habeck da im
wirtschaftsministerium ist er wirklich
der mann mit genügend fachwissen mit
genügend kenntnis um deutschland als
wirtschaftsminister durch diese krise
mit zu steuern und ehrlicherweise habe
ich da schon länger meine zweifel aber
wir sehen jetzt doch immer mehr dinge
auftritte auch die wirklich einen stark
daran zweifeln dass man hat fast den
eindruck das wirtschaftsministerium ist
so etwas wie ein krimi zentrum wo man
sich erstmal über monate ausprobieren
kann nein das ist es nicht das ist kein
trainingszentrum in dem man probieren
kann testen kann was einem spaß macht
das funktioniert nicht dieses
wirtschaftsministerium ist ein zentrales
ministerium gerade in dieser krise wurde
geführt von wirklich schillernden
figuren ludwig erhard otto graf
lambsdorff karl schiller und jetzt sitzt
robert habeck der und man hat der tüftel
ein bisschen probiert aus liegt daneben
die kita nehmen und kann nicht mal
erklären was eine insolvenz ist das ist
für diesen standort eine echte gefahr
dazu jetzt hier bei uns im studio bild
chefredakteur johannes b grüß dich guten
morgen wie weit ist der
wirtschaftsminister aktuell von der
wirklichkeit entfernt das wird morgen ja
es ist in der tat vollkommen absurd denn
das was habe ich da ja einerseits
beschreibt ist eine klassische insolvenz
nämlich als wirtschaftsunternehmen habe
ich laufende kosten kann aber meine
produkte nicht mehr produzieren folglich
nicht mehr absetzen verkaufen aber also
keine einnahmen aber ausgaben das führt
in die insolvenz die es in deutschland
übrigens auch gesetzlicher sehr streng
geregelt also es gibt
insolvenzverschleppung heißt er
beschreibt etwas
und leugnet aber dass er das beschreibt
sagt das sind eigentlich gar keine
insolvenzen und da erkenne ich ein
wirtschaftsminister der die realität
nicht mehr wahrnehmen möchte vielleicht
ja deshalb nicht weil sie die folge
seiner politik ist hp hat ja auch gesagt
er sieht keine insolvenzwelle auf uns
zurollen hier in deutschland wie siehst
du das ich sehe eine riesige
insolvenzwelle auf uns zurollen das ist
klipp und klar wir haben in bild immer
wieder jetzt auch unternehmen
beschrieben die es einfach nicht mehr
schaffen zu produzieren oder die ihre
dienstleistungen nicht mehr anbieten
können und die gehen in einem ford
insolvent zu wir hatten zum beispiel
eine wäscherei die die stromkosten nicht
mehr bezahlen kann sind in der wäscherei
natürlich besonders hoch weil die
waschmaschinen die ganze zeit laufen das
kann man nicht einfach aus der marge
nehmen also aus dem was eigentlich beim
unternehmen hängen bleibt das ist zu
wenig um diese explodierenden kosten zu
tragen es gehen schon unternehmen
insolvent und da würde ich mir und ich
glaube auch viele bürgerinnen und bürger
außer mir sich einen ganz anderen
wirtschaftsminister wünschen der auf
dieses thema wirklich ein geht statt es
zu verleugnen aktuelle beispiele hakle
gehört der schuhhersteller was ist dein
eindruck schafft es der
wirtschaftsminister habe ich noch ist er
überfordert kann er das noch er ist
vollkommen überfordert und zwar erkenne
ich hier ein wirtschaftsminister der
zwischen seiner ideologie und dem
notfall in dem wir uns eigentlich
befinden nicht den richtigen weg findet
er verharrt wahnsinnig an dem was seine
partei die grünen seit vielen
jahrzehnten gefordert haben und das
allerschlimmste und erstaunlichste auch
gestern in diesem clip bei der ard den
wir gerade eben gesehen haben finde ich
ist eine stelle die zeigt wie er sich da
verändert nämlich er flüchtet sich im
selbstmitleid und larmoyanz es gibt eine
stelle da sagt der wirtschaftsminister
dieses landes er selber habe es ja schon
lange nicht mehr geschafft mal in ruhe
zu frühstücken oder serie zum bäcker zu
gehen da kann ich nur sagen viele viele
millionen bürgerinnen und bürger in
diesem land sind in allergrößter not wir
haben sorge dass sie im winter heizen
können die haben sorge dass im winter
das licht ausgeht und dass da der
wirtschaftsminister wenn er nach einer
insolvenzwelle gefragt wird davon
berichtet dass ihnen die zeit für ein
ausführliches oder ein gemütliches
frühstück fehlt das ist völlig daneben
und da sieht man wie er sich verirrt